e
[Music]
good morning everyone and welcome to the
house committee on Health and Human
Services and elderly Affairs we have 13
bills that we're going to be uh working
on this morning in a work session and I
know there's one or two folks here that
want to speak to uh to at least a couple
of them um and we have an executive
session scheduled for this afternoon
where we're hoping to make some
recommendations on these 13 bills in the
meantime however I'd like you to please
Allegiance I pledge allegiance to the
flag of the United States of America
through the Republic for which it stands
one nation under God individual with
all thank you everyone
we're going to go a little bit out of
order this morning uh we have a number
of uh folks here um and uh we think um
you know we'll we'll deviate from the um
schedule a little bit and start off with
HB
1067 um and I believe Lindsay Taylor
speak
I'm just going to say um as a
preliminary matter that it is unusual
for people to come and testify in a work
session so um this is this is not our
normal practice so sure I
understand good morning good morning can
you push the button so that your
microphone turns on good morning I'm
Lindsay Taylor Jackson and I'm making a
film following people with endometriosis
and I'm here to tell my personal story
today
I once was a happy kid who had friends
was athletic and loved going to school
at 10 years old it all changed I began
experiencing pain so intense it felt
like a serrated knife was slicing and
twisting through my abdomen for the next
13 years despite endless tests and
doctor's appointments I remained
undiagnosed I had excessive absences
from school at 23 I got my first surgery
and diagnosis endometriosis and signs
pointing to possible adenomiosis I began
a medical journey of hell for the next
several years I spent a majority of my
20s into my 30s Bleeding Out 24/7 365
days a
year my extra large overnight pads soak
through within an hour I needed to
frequent ER visits to make sure nothing
was rupturing each visit came with fears
of would I need a blood transfusion
could this be fatal multiple doctors
shot me down for hysterectomy because of
my age and being in childbearing years I
was once told I've seen women change
their minds you'll be depressed one day
when you inevitably change your mind and
want children how could doctors allow
their personal opinions of procreation
into their operating rooms I did what I
could to survive I was a cinematographer
on a film about women through hikers on
the Appalachian Trail in
2016 I was supposed to film the entire
2,000m Trail but could only hike 630 M
with 50 lbs on my back because I was
bleeding out and blacking out from the
pain and blood loss the entire time I
left to go get another two surgeries the
non-stop bleeding and excruciating pain
caused me countless work opportunities
and career advances over the years I got
to a point where I couldn't even stand
up most days I slept 20 hours a day and
army crawled my way to the bathroom the
pain was blinding the non-stop blood
loss was dizzying and the Depression was
severe in the years that followed I
tried harsh medications medications I
found out later were not actual
treatments but were experimental
Band-Aids that I fear were only aimed to
preserve my uterus these medications
have left permanent physical damage I
never had a choice and was so desperate
for any relief and was refus to
hysterectomy time and time again I made
it clear for every doctor that I have
always known I do not want kids I've
never wanted children physically I want
any physically I wanted any disease out
of my body and wanted to stop bleeding
24/7 I tried drugs with intense side
effects over almost a decade that
depleted my finances I had to take out
my entire 401K I also had to accept
endless financial help from my parents I
gave up my dreams of going to grad
school as there was no way I could
afford the future I had always
envisioned when I was being forced to
plan for a future I had never even
wanted when I was 31 I found a surgeon
who listened to my story she validated
that none of my choices none of the
choices Made For Me should have been
anyone's but mine she gave me a total
hysterctomy me and gave me my life and
my dignity back these choices need to be
more accessible I am in front of you as
a citizen who suffered greatly within
our failing
systems I am hopeful that by telling you
my story today you can at least
understand what many of us have faced
while deciding what your future laws
dictate and when considering bills like
this everyone should be able to Define
what their own quality of life looks
like thank you thank you are you taking
questions or do does the committee have
any
questions I'm seeing none thank you okay
thank
you also Maggie KH has requested to
speak and again we all limitting all
comments to three
minutes Mr chairman again I'm going to
just say this is not a public hearing
sure no I I understand I my
understanding was that the sponsor was
going to speak and that was it well
representative Reed is actually the
so representative Weber do you it's it's
your call okay I it's just it's very
unusual to have a repeat of a public
hearing and if we are to do that for
every bill that we have today that's
going to make it a long no that is that
is not my intent but but okay y
please yeah hit the button so the red
comes on all right thank you my name is
Maggie K I was born and raised in New
Hampshire I always knew I did not want
children I suffered from endometriosis
that started affecting my life as soon
as I entered puberty I'm not sure if you
folks are aware but at the time that I
went to conquered high school they had a
rule where if you miss 13 classes in a
semester you can't you have to repeat
that grade my grade averages were in the
'90s but I missed more than 13 classes
because my menstrual cycle would make me
vomit uncontrollably for two or 3 days
every single month the only solution I
was offered was opiates and ibuprofen I
was just told to take more Ibuprofen now
at 51 I can't take ibuprofen because it
wrecked my stomach I suffered for years
I did end up getting my GED and I was
able to complete College because of
online classes that I could attend when
I could attend them I went on to have a
great career but I was styed in my
career based on the fact that I had to
miss work one or two days every single
month unless my period fell on a weekend
and it's not just pain that I could
power through or take medication to
solve I would vomit uncontrollably and
you can't go to work if you're vomiting
all day long this is a problem that
women face all the time I was not
offered any solutions maybe they didn't
have good ones back then but they do
today people can get hysterectomies we
shouldn't be required to keep organs
that are holding us back and destroying
our lives just in case someday we want
to have children I'm 51 years old I
never had children because I didn't want
children I've never regretted this I'm
not sad or depressed I don't have kids
I'm a little resentful that I was held
back in my schooling and my career
because I had a disease that would
affect my fertility to treat and some
future hypothetical
man or child was more important than me
who was living my life every single day
so this is an issue that does need to be
addressed regardless of what people
think and that's all thank you thank you
very
much okay um terms of in ter since we
are on this bill we may as well continue
to discuss it committee members any
input you have on HB 1067 for the work
session this morning
representative Leon uh thank you Mr
chairman um I think that the bill had
was definitely narrowed down a lot from
how it was initially introduced because
the bill as we had it and we retained a
study was to allow for um just a a
choice um sterilization or hysterectomy
and then also when there's a medical
treatment and um it's just being denied
a medical treatment is being denied
because of the expectation of future
wishes um I do think that looking
forward it probably will be more
convincing to people to Simply look at
the when somebody is dealing with
debilitating side effects and um not
it's not the medical side that's being
prioritized but potential future
emotional May that may be a more
effective way in order to make sure that
people that women are not denied care um
I do want to note as well that this bill
was placed into the patients Bill of
Rights we all thought that that would be
a good position for that however we've
come to learn that that deals with
facilities and not for health care in
general um so that that may be an issue
for the future as well however um I do
want to thank you for sharing your
stories and I'm sorry that you had those
stories that you need to share I wish uh
you could have had treatment sooner so
thank you thank you representative Leon
other comments from committee members
other thoughts representative papovich
mu thank you I'll be very brief since
I'm a guest for the day but I'm also a
co-sponsor on this and I appreciate all
the work the committee put into
exploring the different things that we
need to do to make this better and uh
you know I hope that it will have a
positive recommendation but either way
the bill is uh coming back and looking
forward to that uh debate next cycle
thank
you thank you any other comments from
committee members on this bill sure okay
I'm seeing done all right if there's no
further comments from committee members
let's go back to the top of the list to
HB 554 FN representative Nagel you have
done a lot of work on this you've
chaired the subcommittee on this had
some very productive meetings and thank
you for your work and please share it
with us thank you Mr chairman thanks for
those kind words but I'm going to
deflect them all to representative
lungren who's brought up this bill in
various for uh forms over the years so I
think a lot of credit goes to him um
just as a background the bill is there
was an opioid crisis uh prescription
drugs had something to do with that and
that one of the reasons why there was an
opioid crisis was because we failed to
provide altern access to Alternative
treatments um there's a long reason we
need to go into great discussion about
that but the whole point of this bill
was to increase access to Alternative
therapies um it's been presented at
least four times um this bill kind of
got merged into a bill that I wrote um
um and it created kind of a major flaw
that we really needed to fix and that's
why we put this to interim study um we
had two great meetings on this bill um
and interestingly the the most important
um presentation during the entire time I
thought came from representative Murphy
and representative Dolan separately um
representative Dolan was representing um
representative lungren initially and he
just basically gave us a story and told
us why this bill was important and that
really kind of accelerated the value of
what we were doing representative Murphy
um when we had our first discussion we
actually did this as a discussion um
with stakeholders and and representative
Murphy talked to them and asked them why
not and and that also accelerated the
discussion to make us feel why this was
important to keep going so we ended up
voting on it six to nothing we also
actually did work to um six to nothing
to proceed and um we actually started
working on the bill the new bill as part
of that process it was great to be part
of this and thank you thank you I know
some of the others here were on that
subcommittee um I know representative we
you were representative Murphy were you
on the sub committee do we have you
or um thank you I'm H I'm happy to speak
on it and I I think that representative
Nel did a great job of um shepherding uh
cats through a somewhat difficult uh
problem um I think we all recognized in
the practice of medicine that there was
an opioid crisis and uh we have made
substantial steps in the last 20 years
to uh improve upon that my my hesitation
always has been to legislate you know
the the practice of medicine having said
that there are also uh many um um
safeguards in place at the current time
which deal with you know continue Med
medical education board recertification
Etc to maintain that people are aware of
the opid crisis um but my also my other
plea was to make sure that in this
discussion that the insurance companies
are keenly aware of and are involved in
the um uh in the decisions that we make
going forward so I I I think that there
would be many things that were in the
bill that were initially I thought
should not be uh part of the the demands
or the mandates for uh insurance
companies or practitioners meaning
things like making sure that you have
enough practitioners and facilities in
an area I mean that's almost impossible
to do so some of that stuff will have to
be um um vetted out um but having said
that uh my two major concerns were and I
won't be here in the next legislative
session to um uh help Shepherd this
through though I may be sitting on that
side of the aisle uh when this bill
comes forward I I think that it would be
very important that we do not legislate
the practice of medicine you know in any
bill that we put forward but also that
when we do so that all stakeholders
including insurance carriers are part of
the discussion and part of the solution
going forward otherwise I think it's
doomed to failure so I think that we we
came across um uh we did a lot to um
establish the fact that this bill should
probably go forward but that it should
be vetted in a way that makes sense for
all the stakeholders involved thank you
thank you representative Nal thanks you
said all the greatest things and I just
wanted to say that I was really honored
with how many people were involved in
this process um including the insurers
who came to our meetings and that was
wonderful and I also did want to say to
the people in yellow that what we're
talking about has some value for you too
we hope because I've heard your story
way too many times and it's very sad um
but thanks thank you representative ever
did you want to speak at all on this I
subcommittee this may have been the
subcommittee that I could never figure
out whether I was on or not but I
certainly agree with everything that's
been said so far so I'll leave it there
it's certainly an issue that needs to be
uh looked at continuously going forward
thank you anyone
else okay seeing no one else uh with a
comment on this um let's move on to HB
580 FN I've been remiss announcing what
the purpose of each bill
was uh HB 580 FN EST is establishing a
child's vision screening initiative
within the State Medicaid Program any
thoughts by committee members on
this representative
Weber I'm I'm thinking that maybe
representative Shapiro may have some
thoughts on it as well but I I think
it's I think it's a very
worthwhile um initiative and I think we
ought to explore it further and and time
to come um because uh the issue of
children's vision and appropriatly
intervention
is an important one so I would I would
suggest we ought to recommend it for
further legislation okay representative
Shapiro I don't know if you're quite
settled in yet but did you have any
bill okay
okay well yeah it's 580 about the
children's vision screening initiative
but obviously we'll be addressing that
further this afternoon in the executive
session so if you want to speak
then okay great anyone
else moving on to HB 608 FN establishing
a pilot program to support the Bureau of
Developmental Services
redesign um I had heard that there might
be one or two people who wanted to speak
to that I don't know if they still do
um anyone in the
audience seeing no one committee members
thoughts representative
Weber I'll just ask for my memory to be
refreshed is this not something that's
been um partially dealt with at least by
the department going in a different
direction for the design and therefore
we've kind of moved on from where we
were and I think one of the reasons that
we were holding on to this was to see
where they went with their new Direction
but um it seems to me that for this one
the time may have come and gone and
there may be there may be new filings
based on current progress but that this
one perhaps is not there is a provision
bill that has a deadline of June 30th
2024 I did speak with uh the department
on um associate commissioner sanon on
Monday and the department has been
addressing many of the aspects of this
and they don't they don't think it's
that's necessary at this point so so
you're absolutely correct and and may I
end sure uh my recollection is that this
was one of a set of three or four
different bills that were
filed at a time when recipients of
services and families were particularly
distressed at the direct
that might be going in service providers
and so I I want to be sure that we
acknowledge um that what we need to do
going forward is a more collaborative
effort but I think that I think that
perhaps there a result of the filing of
all of these bills that point was made
loud and clear so thank you
representative Lon uh thank you Mr
chairman this bill was introduced at the
beginning of the term in a time of great
uncertainty regarding the redesign of
the Bureau of Developmental Services um
it was retained by the committee to
continue the discussion which happened
in the spring of um 2023 and the fall of
2023 on this issue there was a lot of
good discussion that did bring
stakeholders together and had a chance
to speak about this publicly and move
towards a solution um with that we had
recommended nrm study to keep this alive
so that it could continue as a for if it
was needed um now we've moved forward
we've moved past that this has served
its purpose and this bill is not needed
for future legislation because it's
already done its job um but I'm thankful
for the committee to for keeping it an
interim study because it did keep that
Forum
alive anyone
else representative Murphy thank you Mr
chairman mine is mostly a question um as
I wrote down in our notes on March 13th
we actually
um um voted with representative Lon you
know um making the motion to retain the
bill and this was to keep keep it quote
as I wrote it down to keep it moving but
to have HHS oversight uh potentially
have a followup with a committee uh to
evaluate and my question is most mostly
or my comment is mostly a question as to
where do we stand right now and will HHS
oversight um um put forward a committee
to recommend or look at this bill or
this where do we stand with is what I'm
stand asking representative Leon uh
thank you mrman thank you for that
question when we had put this together
we were hoping that we'd be able to work
on it as an interim study during the
term however we had to wait until all
the other bills were dealt with in order
to meet as an interim study by that time
um speaking with area agencies and
speaking with others they felt that the
process was moving along they had a good
collaborative relationship um they do
have to report to Health and Human
Services oversight that's an ongoing
issue but I don't think that it's at the
level of needing a committee and I trust
those on oversight to make that
committee at this point if it's
necessary thank
you other comments or
questions seeing none okay I'm moving on
to hb1010 relative to expanding
maternity options in Midwifery access
any
thoughts representative enal um thanks
um one of the terms that I have learned
in two years that I have never heard
before was this concept of scope creep
and it's viewed as a negative thing and
in some circles and a positive thing in
other circles as a middle child born on
a Wednesday I kind of look at it from
the middle I think in certain
circumstances it can be a great thing
and what that basically means is that
different medical special or you know
people decide to take more um
responsibility within their a scop of
practice um like for example I do
epidural injections I've done 64,000 of
them when I started that was not in my
scope of practice that was an anesthesia
thing but now I do it um this is one of
those things we've had four bills in our
session now where there was a scope of
practice issue one was the Optometry
Bill one was the physicians assistant
Bill one was this bill and then there
was a physical therapy bill um I have
absolutely no problem with people asking
for the right to do more if they do
their due diligence to develop the skill
level that they can to be able to do it
for the physical therapist they did that
for the other three they have not and
when I presented this bill to people
that work with midwives on a regular
basis um I got a deer in the headlights
look like no no no no they said they
don't have the skill level to do this
and one of the things that I'm very
aware of having been involved in four
obstetrical emergencies too with my own
children is that things can go from bad
to worse really fast and they said that
whenever a midwife has to do a delivery
on a child of the type that's specified
in this bill that they have to make sure
that they have extra resources available
in the O whether the Midwife knows it or
not they have to do that because they
don't have the ability to deal with
those emergencies and that's why I don't
really I don't support this in any way
shape or form um I don't know Midwifery
well enough to know what kind of skill
level they need to get to be able to do
these things but in this group of
patients specified in this bill I have a
problem with that and so I won't be
supporting
it thank you representative
Shapiro
um yes having having been present at my
daughter's um breach
um vaginal birth um this is kind of
close to my heart it was in a hospital
with a doctor with Decades of experience
um my main problem with this bill is
that my understanding is it's the
Midwifery
Council that is tasked with um
overseeing the scope of practice for Lay
midwives and then we're then we're
proposing a bill that tells the
Midwifery Council what they
can what they can do and what they can't
do when they are the ones that are
tasked with
um deciding on scope of practice so it
seems contradictory to me um so I'm not
in favor of of um moving this bill
forward okay thank you representative
Murphy thank you Mr chairman um I guess
part of the um process this morning will
be to um um restimulate some of our
memories of what happened back in the
springtime uh we looked at this bill and
I specifically asked the Midwifery
Council uh would they support the bill
and they said absolutely not number two
I also put in in again regarding the
whole concept of practice scope creep
etc etc I'm not sure I understand it
fully but having said that and been a
practitioner for many years if you were
to change the Midwife title in the
analysis section of this bill and just
put it as there experienced physician
with Decades of experience they would
still not you know support the bill as
written so for those reasons Al and
because there's no experience you know
OBGYN that will deliver a you know
multiair you know um multiple fetuses
within a uterus uh breach presentation
30 miles away from home etc etc so um if
you were to basically substitute the
word Midwife and put experienced
physician with Decades of experience
they would still not vote for this bill
so I would vote against it unless it's
been changed substantially thank you
thank you representative King and then
representative question for the chair um
was this a bill that was actually worked
on over the summer were there any
subcommittee hearings on this or because
so far it sounds like we've basically
heard things objections that we would
get during executive session and it
would be nice I mean unfortunately
representative kushman's not here I
imagine she would have been on that
subcommittee I don't know I just would
like a more work session out of this as
opposed to just should and answer your
question no that was not worked on over
summer that uh we had done a number of
surveys um our committee assistant had
done a number of surveys and there
wasn't the interest from committee
members to work on it uh so nothing was
done on it and um we do have to make a
decision though ideally today in terms
of recommending or not recommending but
um to answer your question no nothing
was done over the summer representative
Glon uh thank you Mr chairman um
representative sh here I'm so glad your
daughter was able to have um have that
type of delivery as opposed to being
required to have a cesarian SE um
section to deliver um her child in 2019
when I was temporarily in the position
of breach I was speaking to my hospital
and the others available and because of
legal concerns they no longer conducted
they would only do a cesarian even when
they had training because of legal
concerns uh because uh because the
actuaries were too worried about the wh
ifs you were not permitted to have a
vaginal breach birth in New Hampshire in
the hospitals at least the ones that I
spoke to that were close enough to my
home um with this you are leaving women
the option of either consenting to the m
the surgery maybe if they're already a
tried and tested mother with a team
that's comfortable of doing this you're
denying her that opportunity or you're
asking her to free birth and then show
to the hospital if there's a consequence
or to go out State because in
Massachusetts this can be done um I know
that the bill as written um um had some
serious serious questions for a lot of
people but I do think that we're not
just talking about what we can have the
practice of the past where you had
doctors who were experienced in vaginal
bre breach deliveries because those
don't happen in hospitals anymore um
we're now looking at the fact that those
simply are cesarians if that is a
presentation and
um and I believe I believe in people
being able to have more agency in their
choices um so so I do think that we do
need to have a discussion because you're
not talking about women who are going to
be going to the hospital you also have
women who will be free birthing because
they can't have an experienced attendant
um so it's an issue that we need to talk
about because of moms and babies and the
fact that as we've had a more and more
concentrated Health Care System there's
a lot more a lot of times when the
lawyer's in the room with the doctor
it's not just the doctor and the patient
um but I appreciate your concerns
because there's a reason why we make
sure we have such a robust system in the
past we lost too many moms and babies
we're trying to minimize that but we
need to acknowledge that nothing is
riskless so thank you and and I I see
the way that the things are going on
this one but I did want to make the
point that without permitting that
you're asking a woman to go out of state
unless she wants to consent to surgery
to deliver her her
child uh representative Nagel and then
representative Shapiro this is more a
question for those way more experienced
than I am on on what we're doing today
but
I don't think there's a bill here that
we're looking at that doesn't have some
amount of Merit that could probably be
made better that we could probably do
better with study or whatever recommend
something in the
future I'm trying to understand what
we're trying to accomplish here
representative
Weber well traditionally the responses
have been all over the lot to interim
study because we interim study bills for
a whole bunch of different reasons and
it sounds to me like we have one I mean
sometimes we keep them to see what's
going to happen we think there's been a
resolution to a problem we're not sure
that the resolution's going to work we
keep them around to work on you know and
see if in in case we need them that's
one and we've already had one where it
sounded like our discussion was handing
in that direction today it's clearly a
bill whose time has come and gone there
are other things where I think
reasonable parties disagree as to what
our mission is
because uh this is
not a time for us to come up with an
actual bill going forward that can only
be done by the next
legislature and so it's really giving
our sense as to how far we've gotten in
a discussion of what what might come up
and I know there's a bill coming up F NE
at some point where there has been
significant more discussion and and we
can talk about that an actual PR on word
smithing but again that has to happen
next time so in in many ways it's a
matter of word smithing a report I mean
I have actually written a
report
um that uh says that um everybody on the
committee agreed that further action was
needed we were completely opposed as to
what that action should be and I wrote
the two opposing positions so uh you
come out all kinds of different ways um
and and certainly no matter what the
vote is I would assume that there is
more than room in the writing of the
report to acknowledge an underlying
problem uh and you know what what we
think ought to be done with it is only
interesting because it's for the next
legislature to
Shapiro I actually have a lot of mixed
feelings of about this bill because I do
feel like um patients should have choice
and
um and you know including taking more
risks um because it's something that's
really important to them um and
um I don't necessarily think we should
give the right of providers to to to um
proide services that they're not
that is overly risky so I I have mixed
feelings about it I'm I'm going to rely
on representative Murphy who seems to
take notes and actually can find his
notes about these things but my memory
is that
when and this is not to contradict you
representative Leon but my memory is
that when we had this discussion we had
this hearing and when um medical
providers
testified that that they said that there
it was possible to get a um a vaginal
breach um delivery in New Hampshire now
it might not be it might not be at every
hospital and it might not be um you know
there might be problems with that that
the like the doctor who actually does
that might not might be on vacation or
something but that it wasn't impossible
but anyway I I just that's just a memory
that um
that I had that I wanted to bring
forth representative papich Mueller
again as a late Comer and a one day
visitor all I want to say is that I
appreciate learning about what was done
earlier but I would not consider it
wasn't impossible to be reasonable an
reasonable option for patients it if if
we give them options they have to be
options that are reasonably feasible not
you know if you jump through 15 Hoops
maybe you'll get lucky and get that I
know that's not what you meant but when
you talk about standards right what is
the standard that we use that's very
important discussion and I would think
we need something better than it's not
completely impossible that's all thank
you and I know that was not your intent
to go there but representative Leon and
then representative Murphy um thank you
Mr chairman one of the things that we do
is we um try not to confront Witnesses
or necessarily ask questions that aren't
getting us to a solution and simply or
to try and F it out what's going on uh
the I believe that the provider who said
that they happen at their hospital was
at the same hospital where I was denied
that option so it it's one of those
areas where it's hard to say well I
disagree because of facts and my facts
contradict what somebody is coming to
testify for us but in that scenario I
believe that provider was at the same
facility that told me that that was not
an option so we're here trying to deal
with people and information that we have
and that's why it's a challenging job so
but I appreciate that representative
Murphy thank you um thank you Mr
chairman uh it only in response to
representative Shapiro's question um we
did have that conversation uh with the
um uh practitioners and they also did
say that there are multiple options
available for having C or having vaginal
deliveries with breach presentations in
multipar uh multiple uh fetuses within
the
uterus you know the um the idea that you
know having a delivery is an emergency
is is not true I mean often times it is
and often times it comes without warning
and you have to deal with it as you have
to deal with it but the majority of the
time people are have the option of where
they can call up a hospital and say will
so and so be able to deliver this I
would love to have this vaginally and
they'll say yes we have the experience
to do that so yes the answer to your
question was yes they um that there was
Hampshire other comment uh
representative King I have a question
for everybody actually um I just reread
the bill and I think I may have
misunderstood it the when we first when
it was first presented several months
ago um and I don't know why may maybe my
memory is fuzzy but my understanding was
that the bill made sure that um women
always have access or options to
midwives um um but I'm I'm rereading it
it almost sounds like um this would kind
of force hospitals to allow midwives to
work within the hospital system can
somebody just explain to me in layman's
terms what this bill
does um representative L uh thank you Mr
chairman uh this is around what the
midwives are able to do um if they're
required to deny care or if they're
required to transfer care of a woman
because her condition has gone beyond
her beyond the scope
um that's what it deals with it's not
talking about needing to requiring the
hospitals to permit them to come and
practice it's simply about whether or
not that that Midwife can continue to
provide care for that woman okay thank
you then my understanding was correct
originally and which is why I support
the bill um because to me it just seems
weird that in this state you have the
legal ability to terminate a pregnancy
but you wouldn't have the ability to use
use a midwife when you want to that
seems highly incongruous thank you
representative Nagel and then
representative Shapiro and again tell me
if I'm wrong but to me this is totally a
scope of practice bill that allows them
to deliver certain types of deliveries
and certain settings that they may or
may not be qualified to do and setting
them up for you know consequences for
that and that in the end we all pay for
um so that's the way I read this bill is
a scope of practice Bill representative
chapero I'm glad to be corrected but
um if I'm not
mistaken there are there are two levels
of Midwifery certification one is a
nurse Midwife who may have
um who may have the um ability to to
practice in a hospital and deliver
babies in a hospital the the the the
certification of midwives that we're
talking about and I I know they're not
referred to as lay midwives but I don't
know the proper um
terminology um but we're talking about
people who
would generally or only be delivering
babies um outside of hospitals I I
believe representative Lon uh yes the
certified nurse midwives are the ones
that practice in the hospitals um those
are the ones where they're on staff in
some of our hospitals the certified
midwives is the title we have for it
here in New Hampshire you have different
degree requirements and they're the ones
who are helping women all around the
state especially as we're closing our
obstru our our deliveries but they do
not practice in hospitals is correct
they do not practice in
hospitals representative Murphy I I
would just like to clarify again what I
think is the rule that is
written in the analysis here and is
basically says a Midwifery Council which
governs the you know the oversight you
know just like the Board of Medicine or
the you know uh generates um uh
evaluations of our practices in general
they it says a mid referee Council shall
not adopt rules limiting care so what
there really is is a scope of practice
you know restriction basically saying
that the mid wre Council will not be
able to put into place rules that prot
protect the fetus and the baby and the
mother you know in certain circumstances
that are listed here including you know
presentation number of you know prior
C-sections distance from a hospital Etc
so it is a scope of practice you know um
Bill representative King thank you for
that clarification uh representative
Murphy can you tell me who created the
Midwifery Council um and and you know
because if it was created by an act of
legislation then ultimately The
Authority still rests with us that's I
just I don't
know representative Murphy I do not know
okay any other comments on um HB 106 uh
HB 1010 I'm sorry um any other
comments seeing none okay moving on um
to HB 1347 relative to administration of
the New Hampshire Refugee resettlement
program
that yes representative
Weber um I I have to say frankly that I
thought that this was u a very
inadvisable bill when it was filed um
and the provisions in it that said that
until all of the social determinants of
Health were satisfied for every single
citizen um that we would
not expend funds
for um
immigrants was particularly in advised
and if I recall correctly the sponsor
came to us and said that he had filed it
in a moment where he perhaps was not
paying quite as much attention to what
um was in front of us or what was
as all of us have concerns about
immigration and
how we relate to the Immigrant community
and that perhaps we ought to think about
it some more um it seemed to me that
this was a
particularly inappropriate vehicle to do
that thinking so I would suggest that it
not be referred for further um
legislation along these lines although I
am quite certain that the issue is one
the issue broadly is one that will come
up regularly going forward but I thought
I frankly thought that this as drafted
which may I'm not attributing motive
I but as drafted it seemed to me to be
particularly mean-minded and I I take
the sponsor at his word that it was not
what he was intending representative
Leon and then representative
uh thank you Mr chairman um within the
language of the bill there was reference
to wait list I think that a lot of this
was looking at the number of people who
have unmet needs um who were waiting for
services that the state has said that
they'll provide if they have the money
so it was looking to take those State
funds uh there's so many complex
interactions between the federal funding
agreements and state law that the bill
is completely unworkable and even taking
a seed of looking at dealing with the
weight lists it's going to anything to
deal with that would have to take such a
different form that that I I would
suggest that we not recommend this for
future legislation representative
Shapiro yes thank you Mr chairman as
much as I personally would love to see
um the legislature be involved in some
kind of really broad fair-minded
discussion about the effects of
immigration in New Hampshire and the
benefits and the problems
um I I don't and and and um
in my in my personal conversations with
that he also wanted to have maybe for
different reasons than myself have a
discussion about immigration because
it's such a big issue in our country um
and so I I would agree with um
representative Weber that he had already
rethought this particular bill when he
brought
and um it was particularly flawed
because um the the department of refugee
resettlement within DHHS which is very
small and um helps to coordinate with
the with the private nonprofit
resettlement agencies that work in New
Hampshire um the department within the
Department of Health and Human Services
is very small is completely is is I I
believe one um staff member um and
limited funds and it's completely
federal funds so the bill was referring
to State funds um and I
think the sponsor realized that it
wasn't really relevant and I would agree
that it's not really relevant so if
there's some kind of Bill on
immigration um that comes forward next
um session I I don't think it would
really be related to this specific bill
so I I would agree with um the other
people who have spoke that it um we
should not recommend it go forward thank
you representative Murphy thank you Mr
chairman I I couldn't agree more with uh
representative Leon and representative
Shapiro as well that having some bill
regarding immigration would be great but
this is not the bill nor the platform on
which it should be established and I
have the quote that was taken back in
March um by representative Edwards I
really don't like this bill I doubt we
could ever amend this bill in any way in
any acceptable manner so I think the the
prime sponsor was one who basically felt
the same way that even with amendments
we were not going to make it a good
enough Bill to address the issues of
immigration that you speak of thank you
1347 I'm seeing none okay moving on to
HB 1661 FN relative to immunization
report rep in requirements any thoughts
on
Shapiro yes thank you Mr chairman I see
a number of problems with this um bill
um as I understand it um this bill um
would
require certificates of death who um you
know which might be signed off on by a
medical examiner but most likely would
be signed off on a physician a
hospitalist or uh you know a Family
Doctor Who whoever is dealing with the
person who's at the end of their life um
it would add the requirement that um a
history of vaccinations be included in
that death certificate I just think that
that is
um Way Beyond the scope of what um the
normal person who the normal physician
who's signing off on these generally
does and it would incre create an
incredible burden of having to um go
back in history and find all that
information and write it so that's
that's one problem I have with it um
another problem is that it calls for
DHHS to do quarterly reports um that
aggregate all this
information um and to try to find
um connections between
um between the history of
vaccinations and um and those deaths so
that is a I I don't believe the Bill
calls for hiring more staff for DHHS or
um money for maybe the technology that
would be needed to do this um but that
is also seems to me to be an incredibly
um large requirement that we would be
putting on
DHHS the last um issue that I have with
this bill is the last part of the bill
which um um suggests a
lottery to pick um four different
Auditors to audit this information and I
think um well in short I think that just
opens us up for
um you know breaches of confidentiality
and it's um kind of goes against the um
Trend in our state people really really
want to protect privacy um so for all
those reasons
um I do not think this is a um good bill
for us to pursue thank you
representative
Weber thank you Mr chair and I I I won't
reiterate all of what representative
Shapiro said but I agree with all of it
um the other couple of points that I
thought of is that um when my husband
died at home his hospice nurse did the
certification so that's a whole another
range of people who will have had no
contact with the vaccination status uh
of people in most cases at least um and
the um other concern I had and I'm sorry
I don't have the bill in front of me and
I've managed to leave my laptop at home
so I was going to whip it up and give
you the site but uh there was language
about those
reports that had particularly squishy
language about reporting as appropriate
and as consistent with privacy and I am
sure that in this room in our
discussions among our committee members
it's become very clear that my notion of
personal privacy and my personal privacy
is not the same as other members in this
room and we should each get to Define
that for
ourselves um so I thought that language
was squishy and unhelpful and provided
very little guidance as to
how sensitive stuff was going to be uh
dealt with um also seems like the um
um the folks who presented were able
from Massachusetts data to match up
information and names which seem to me
to be particular particularly
intrusive uh and then the final point
that I would like to make is if we want
usable data that's going to help us make
determinations about
outcomes here we have no control really
about the quality of what's being
reported because on the one hand we have
people who have authorized the reporting
to an optional registry we have people
people who have uh exercised their right
not to be included in a registry and we
have people who have exercised their
right not to take a
knowing who those people are and a and
so that we can evaluate the outcomes
appropriately because some of the people
who have no reporting will have no
reporting because they didn't get a
vaccine and some will have no reporting
because they didn't want to report and
um that results in data that is not
going to be particularly useful if we're
looking at correlation which is really
all we can look at we're not looking at
causation here so thank you thank you uh
representative Murphy and then
representative Lon thank you Mr chairman
um as I reviewed the bill once again I I
I found that there were m multiple
issues that concern me as well including
the privacy issues but you know it goes
beyond that in many ways it becomes a a
burdensome U issue for many
practitioners the list of people that
can
actually um as representative Weber
mentioned the list of people that can
certify a death are are fairly long they
have to be available to certify the
death within 36 hours and in in doing so
they also have to have the computer
information on which to look up the
database and then assess whether or not
the patient had an immunization my other
concern is that why immunization why not
you know do we not look at things like
do they have a total joint in place do
they have a um what were the medication
list you know so the list can go on and
on and on but the death certificate
should simply state that the patient
died in the day patient died this date
and the patient died because of this
reason you want to try to keep it as
simple as possible the kiss principle in
medicine has held up for many decades
and I would try to do the same thing
here as well so I cannot um support this
bill unless it was changed dramatically
over the summer time thank you
representative Leon uh thank you Mr
chairman and uh thank you representative
Murphy for actually bringing up a very
good point about the general idea of
some of the benefit that could come from
a better look post death um given the
complexities you know there are some
areas where it may make sense to have
some sort of comprehensive review about
not only what has been prescribed but
what's been taken if you've been
prescribed certain anti psychotics
you're not taking them and then a very
bad thing happens that may be an
important Public Health interest I I do
think that it would behoove us to look
at how to have a more comprehensive look
around um medical decisions and then
people's outcome either their death or
death that they've caused for others um
but I agree that there's a lot about
this bill that um was not was not
workable and that brought a lot of
challenges um I do want to highlight to
representative Weber I benefited a lot
from um data that came from the Swedish
registry that is a lot more
comprehensive than anything we would
have here because in Sweden they have
one Health Care system and your data
goes in you don't have a choice uh but
even with that there were areas where
there wasn't complete information so you
couldn't analyze every single person in
that group so even if you had some
people who had to be excluded from an
analysis because you were not certain
about their status there's there's ways
statistically to deal with that but I
recognize that there's a lot of
structural issues with the bill um and I
guess we'll see where we move on in the
afternoon but there's no reason to uh
belabor the point at this point so thank
you other
comments saying on let's move on to the
next one which is a 1663 FN which is
relative to the confidentiality of
medical records and patient information
representative Lon uh thank you Mr
chairman this bill sought to provide
protections and Clarity regarding
medical record confidentiality through a
re repal and replace method a
substantial amount of the testimony that
we heard opposing the bill was actually
opposing existing parts of current law
um so I would recommend to myself if I
introduce this in the future to not do a
repeal and replace but to have all the
changes within there so we can discuss
the actual changes to law instead of
getting lost in uh trying to tease out
the differences
um so um there is a need to assess New
Hampshire's protections of patient
privacy in a more rigorous manner
especially given the increased knowledge
around hipa a lot of people thought that
it was all about privacy but in reality
it's about portability and making sure
that Providers Insurance companies um in
some cases people advertising for
different causes um have access to your
medical record within an ecosystem that
is policed to some Manner and some level
federal law does allow us to make state
laws more protective of personal privacy
and I think that given how often privacy
comes up in this committee and in other
parts within the state it does make
sense to look at it in the future
although um I will agree that there were
things that I could have done better on
this bill so hopefully we can recommend
it for future legislation um but I know
it will look different than the way that
I introduced
it other comments representative Nel
thank you Mr chairman yeah that that's
really helpful and I I appreciate all
the points that you rais um it seems to
me you know just looking at the people
that responded to this virtually all the
responses I saw were kind of negative um
mostly because you know I've been
involved in healthcare now for about 40
years and I've I've watched the Health
Care system change dramatically where
there's more and more oversight we spend
more and more time dealing with
paperwork and computers and less and
less time with um patients and that kind
of really screws up the way we practice
healthc care and a lot of them saw this
as as doing that which I think
you raise a a valid point that's a
problem to me like the way I like to
deal with these things is like an ad hoc
multi-stakeholder group this is a
problem how do we fix it how do we solve
it without making your life miserable
and as a doctor I would kind of
appreciate that kind of format to
dealing with this and then coming up
with legislation that respects
everybody's needs and wishes and because
I just think we've been harming healthc
care too much the last 30
years representative Weber
thank you and I I thank you both for
your comments because there's a lot that
I agree with in both of them uh I I
think that this for me personally is an
example of one where um I think the
report writing is going to be delicate I
think I would tend to vote
that this bill this approach is not
something that I think should go forward
but we've already had that
acknowledgement on the approach and that
I I think that the report should
acknowledge that both
privacy and um functionality for
practitioners and uh privacy for
patients and functionality for
practitioners are things of concern to
everyone so in so far as that is um an
ongoing
conversation I I think we're probably
all in agreement that we're going to be
having that conversation in many formats
but uh I think my vote would be that
this is not the
bill to have that conversation on so
coming to different conclusions for
roughly the same reasons which is odd
but other comments representative Murphy
so my mind is mostly a question for the
primary um sponsor of the bill in my to
understand you that you would
not want to go forward with this bill
and Amendment but come up with a
separate legislation you know entirely
separate from this one going forward in
the next legislation uh well thank you
for that if it if we were to move
forward somebody would need to take that
to OS and draft the language uh for one
I would not do it as a repeal and
replace and for the second I would take
a lot of the testimony that we heard in
order to balance the privacy and the
functionality because the last thing I
want to do is add more bureaucracy and
red red tape to assist system that is
already nearly strangled by that um but
I also want to make sure that we're
balancing balancing the different needs
that we have um I don't have one in
drafting for the coming year but there
may be one in the second second year and
that would only be if I work with an
adhawk group but I would rather not sort
of snuff out the light on this uh
because this did have uh bipartisan
sponsorship and so that we could move
forward and work together to make sure
that we're protecting privacy and just
rebuild
so much trust has been lost in all
systems government everything we need to
rebuild that because if we can't rebuild
Trust on a whole we're going to lose the
society that we have and that would be a
shame um but part of that comes with
respecting privacy and respecting and
respecting the ability for doctors and
other practitioners to do their job
without too much um too much red tape so
I think that it's something that if we
had the bandwidth if we had the ability
it would greatly benefit the people of
New Hampshire but it would need to be a
large effort where we get together lots
of stakeholders work hard over a summer
not necessarily through this process um
and then bring some language to the
legislature that's been more fully
vetted uh because this touches everybody
and sometimes it touches you as both a
patient other questions other comments
representative nle you have your
microphone on oh sorry is that an
indication you want to speak no I just
GNA say Amen okay
anyone
else okay saying no one else let's move
on to hb1
1693 which is relative to the use of
psychedelics for therapeutic purposes
representative Lon uh thank you Mr
chairman um I just can't get myself out
of the healthcare world I get the mudcap
news updates all the time and I can't
tell you how many times I've heard
something about a jamama article
comparing psychedelics to existing
anti-depressants and when I've seen that
this is something that's moving forward
in medicine uh right now the VA is doing
some research on it uh Mass General
Hospital has a treatment center and they
have some facilities here in New
Hampshire uh but right now New Hampshire
law prohibits a clinical trial from
happening in the state with psychedelics
because of its status as a controlled
substance um I think that having to send
patients out of state to participate in
this especially if they're dealing with
something like PTSD or end of life fears
um I I think that we should move forward
with a much much much narrower process
in order to make sure that we're not
interfering with a clinical trial
process in a highly supervised um
environment however the idea of trying
to set up an entire alternate ATC
program for psychedelics is unworkable
um that's something that I'd hop to
discuss with the prime sponsor and move
forward however he did not attend the
hearing um and I don't want patients who
could benefit from what the FDA is
designated as a breakthrough therapy to
suffer simply because there wasn't the
effort to work on language um to revise
his bill as opposed to come back in the
future with one that would enable
clinical
trials representative Weber and I would
just say that I agree with absolutely
everything you just said that I think
the the place for the trials is within
the medical community and under strict
supervision but if the medical community
needs the tools for us to be able to do
it we should be helping them so that
anything that shows promise as a
treatment option can be appropriately
evaluated and and moved forward as it is
as it is shown to be useful so thank you
for that representative Nel thank you Mr
chairman I guess that gets me back to
the pragmatics of this because I don't
support this bill as written but I
support everything you just
said is is that like a vote Yes we want
to look at further legislation or say no
I want you to come up with something
totally different next time
representative lay on um so part of it
is if you could agree with this as the
committee report statement New Hampshire
state law currently prevents research
Andor treatments which use psychedelic
drugs despite the expanding Research
into this area the Veterans
Administration and Massachusetts General
Hospital are currently conducting
research for a number of disorders and
the FDA has granted breakthrough therapy
designation for some psychedelics we
recommend future legislation to permit
patients access to clinical trials or
other therapy without the need to cross
state lines for care I could add
language to say in um in a in a
supervised medical one but that that is
my intent of the language so a lot of
this does come down to how we split
hairs about the recommended for future
legislation but I think that if we
narrow the funnel and say what we think
was good about a bill I think that's
helpful for future legislators
question of another person here sure go
ahead representative Murphy sorry do you
Dartmouth because that's a psychedelic
functionally and that you know we used
to have to have patients go to Germany
to get that ketamine infusions for pain
retraction I don't know that for sure I
know that we use ketamine in the O but I
don't know that it's used as a treatment
option uh it would be better asked of
somebody from DH I'm just curious
because we're already doing a
psychedelic you know this is I left DH
about quite a few years ago so I'm not
sure if they do that right now they
might you want to
speak representative Weber I was just
going to say in partial answer to your
earlier question that certainly if
that's the way the report's going to be
written and it's recommended for further
action I I certainly would vote for it I
think I think the devils in
the the the meat of the recommendation
is in how you write the report and that
seems to me to encapsulate all the
concerns that I had and and put out very
clearly uh what might be the scope of
future action
so representative
McKay thank you Mr chairman could
yes I I don't know what that
representative Leon is looking up the
definition so um some of the drugs that
are being researched for you um for
Within These are psilocybin which is
from the mushrooms um MDMA which um is
called ecstasy that one I believe is for
um I believe it's both for PTSD I know
that it's also for um end of life
concerns and fears when people are s
suffering debilitating fears uh there's
been a significant amount of research on
it but a lot of this is looking to use
some of these I guess some are lab
created some are more naturally derived
but um within the scope of this law it
would it would be looking to be a
clinical trial that's been approved from
an IRB most likely um although I'm not
sure exactly how tight we want to get on
this um because we don't want to tie the
hands but the intention would be for a
clinical trial and I know soy and MD and
MDMA both have breakthrough um status
designation at the FD da thank
you representative n i I just wanted to
point out something interesting because
this is my clinical experience but back
in 1990 there was a gentleman that
published a study looking at um elicit
drug trade in New York City and he
identified two different groups of drug
dealers one were the people that dealt
with it for you to get high the other
ones that were dealing drugs to help you
treat a symptom they called themselves
Street doctors and they were totally
illegal totally the reason they were
doing it is because of the HMO
flourishing in that time frame people
couldn't get the drugs they needed what
I've seen in my world that I'm a little
bit silent about is that there's
experimentation going on these drugs
every day and in a substantial
percentage of the patients that I see
all the time there would be certainly a
benefit to having oversight of that from
you know a medical provider that's
really not happening and that's really
why what you said is really important
so representative Weber and then
representative Lon and just in in in
further answer to um representative
McKay's question uh the uh word
psychedelics for the purpose of this
bill is defined specifically as any of
the following sub substances psilocybin
lysergic acid DL LSD and musculine and
then there's a further um
definition of celoc cybin uh meaning
anything that came from that particular
fungus so it is limited to three very
specific
things um but uh I think I think it
still Bears the the issue of let's let's
look at it carefully under controlled
circumstances and if we're standing in
the way of that we ought to figure out
how to quietly and with the least amount
of um intervention get out of the way of
progress representative Leon uh thank
you Mr chairman uh thank you for
bringing up ketamine ketamine is a
schedule three drug um just like binin
and anabolic steroids so those can be
prescribed and that's not against New
Hampshire law schedule two which is RA
opium oxycodone cocaine and Fentanyl uh
those are all can be prescribed within
certain scenarios but all of the drugs
within this are in schedule one which
are their deem as having no medical use
and that's why New Hampshire law would
need to carve out the ability for those
these particular schedule one drugs to
be used um and that's what that's why
it's an issue and that's why we're in
the way
potentially representative Shapero thank
you um I I would certainly um be happy
to um vote Yes on representative Leon's
language I actually feel
um that a broader expansion and legal
ation would be
appropriate um than just clinical
trials but I can't imagine that
happening I mean it just seems like it's
such an enormous amount of work to um
that would have to go into it and we've
seen from the attempts to
legalize um recreational marijuana how
you know the the way every element of a
bill has to be considered and part first
and um so it seems like any broader
expansion of psychedelics would
be enormous amount of work that I don't
see anybody um working on in the legisl
in the legislature um I mean there was
this bill but it was just basically
saying we should legalize all these
things uh and so I think I think the
word the language that you used would be
a very good first step it would be it
would allow certain things to happen in
state that then people could consider
into the
future thank
else okay moving on to the next bill HP
FN relative to notice required prior to
circumcision
procedure anyone have any comments or
thoughts on
that well oh sure go ahead
representative
Nels
um I I had a big problem with the bill
as it is I saw it as a slippery
slope um that would dictate an informed
consent for one specific issue when we
deal with hundreds of thousands of
different medical issues and procedures
and interventions and things like that
with that said the bill brought up the
important issue of informed consent that
I think we're H is in our medical legal
world right now is significantly flawed
um it ceases to use a as a format to
inform patients of what they're getting
into but merely is a means of covering
risk benefit and for the provider having
had to rewrite about 10 informed
consents last year that our Risk
Management Department made me do and
when I saw the outcome of them I was
really appalled because they didn't
inform the patient of anything um so I
did think that this brought up an
incredibly important issue and if we
frame the report in terms of that and
not the specific issue of circumcision
then I'm very supportive of this if it's
the circumcision issue specifically I
that representative Pap M commenting as
a patient and God knows at my age I'm a
patient here and there I have not seen a
informed consent process which I felt
was meaningful in a long long time you
go there they give you the little black
box and they tell you the name of the
form you're signing you don't see it
sure you could ask for it if you are
willing to disrupt their process because
they have five more people waiting I
understand part of why the process
evolved this way is that we do create
all that red tape and the practices have
to be able to streamline their
operations and they meet the law in the
best way they can so I'm not you know
assuming any ill intent but I would
welcome again a more Nuance discussion
on informed consent that would make it
meaningful without hamstringing medical
service providers and I'm in no way
saying this bill is the way to do it but
I think the issue in general deserves
more attention lately thank you
representative Murphy thank you Mr
chairman I I think this is basically
what representative Nagel was getting at
in and also um what you were talking
about as well is
that it's it's hard for me to have a
bill go forward by legislators that
deals with a specific procedure IE
circumcision so you know parents make
informed consents for their for the kids
all the time up up until the age of
their 21 they make informed decisions
for them so you know my question is not
specifically for any future legislation
to be that specific but to be more
generalized with informed consent
informed consent is I would say in my
experience uh gone the way of the dodo
the way of the etel um I think that we
oftentimes do not inform our patients
well enough for instance to get a
informed consent on the day of surgery
to me is not informed consent I mean you
could say to a patient I'm going to take
your arm off and put it on your toe and
they'll say sure I'll sign right here
that just does not work so informed
consent to me is a much broader issue I
I don't and cannot support a bill that
is so specific regarding circumcisions
just like I couldn't be more specific
about any other you know medication or
treatment that we provide between a a
parent and a child so to me any future
legislation I would hope would have to
do with more the informed consent versus
the um specifics of a procedure thank
you representative
Shapero yes
um I would hope that we recommend that
this not be brought for further
legislation um I I I
absolutely um understand that informed
consent is an issue and I cannot fathom
the fact that it won't be brought up in
in in other legislation coming up
um but this bill in my mind people are
probably sick of hearing me talk about
this I'm sick of hearing me talk about
this um this bill in my mind
um while I
understand while I understand the issue
of people feel like they came to the
situation where their child was going to
be circumcised or not with without
adequate information and there should be
more education I support that completely
but in my mind the the the the bill
itself that was brought and the
testimony we heard was so
about about people telling other people
what they should do and what they
shouldn't do and I don't think it's any
I don't think it's the state's business
to tell people what they should do and
and what they shouldn't do
do I I should take that back that's
um in this regard I don't think I don't
think the state has any place in making
it in pressuring people um to make
decisions one way or the other about
circumcision and so I I just felt like
the
whole motivation that this was brought
with um was offensive really offensive
to me and um and so I'm certainly going
to vote that this bill in is not brought
this bill should not be brought forward
in any um in any way representative Lon
um thank you do you mind if I asked that
you apologize for attributing motive on
that I know that I I recognize you
working through that but giving a motive
to that is one of the things that we
um I know we've had really good
discussions on this sort of thing before
I just saying that say giving the motive
in which you had offered it I think is
just a little bit past where we should
be but I respect everything else that
you said you almost became a Libertarian
there too representative
Weber I heard it as uh describing a
perception rather than ascribing a
motive okay then I guess I'll withdraw
that I just wanted to make sure we kept
everything on really good and friendly
terms because we've done such a good job
of
that representative Nal thank you Mr
chair um I think that this gets me back
to the pragmatic issue we had an
absolutely wonderful discussion be on
this issue between this bill and also
another bill that uh representative
kushman brought up about the whole
concept of informed consent and it
really touched a nerve with me and one
of the things that I think that I said
at the time um was that this is an issue
that really warrants further I hate to
do this because everybody hates it when
you say this but further
multi-stakeholder study on some level
that we can actually look at this issue
because I don't think informed consent
works at all right now and I think it's
important that we look at that um
um is that a yes or a no or does it get
back to how do we write up the report
because I would write it up the way I
okay is that a general question yeah
anybody you guys are way smarter than me
I I'm not sure about in my case I'm not
sure that about that but any other
thoughts on representative naval's
question or position representative
King thank you um representative Shapiro
brings up a interesting topic and that
is um the fact that it was so one-sided
during testimony and to me it seems like
the silence is deafening
why if I may ask the representative um
why do you think there was no strong
Lobby or concerned citizens or really
anybody that came out against the bill
why do you think there was I mean it's
if this was really a bad idea why why
didn't anybody come in and articulate
that in testimony thank
you Shapiro representative Shapiro
I'm I'm still kind of mulling over
representative Leon's question of me and
um I'll speak for myself um you know I'm
somebody who's 74 years old um when I'm
Jewish so maybe that had something to do
with why I was circumcised but also my
age almost all men were being
circumcised in the United States
um a lot of the testimony involved um
um being damaged by
circumcision um having PTSD from
circumcision having um a rupture with
their parents because their parents were
the ones that made the decision to
circumcise them her talk about people
um not having satisfactory sex lives
because they were circumcised um so as
one particular
example those things you know I didn't
have any of those experiences so I think
people people the the vast majority of
people who have had the experience of
circumcision
and and I'm not saying it should happen
or it shouldn't happen um you know if if
I was a young parent now I don't know
that I would circumcise a male child um
but I think the vast majority of people
who've had that procedure it just has
not been a problem in their lives so you
know there was not an outpouring of
people coming out in defense of
um of circumcision it's just a non
non-issue for most people for most men I
think
my perception representative Nal you
really touched a nerve for me I this is
the problem I have with the legislative
process and why I like ad hoc groups um
is that it's a you snooze you lose type
thing you know if you're not aware that
this is going on you're not coming here
they came here with an organized group
of PE a really organized group of people
there's not an organized group of people
out there that says I love circumcision
you know with t-shirts and whatever you
know it doesn't exist and so most people
aren't even wear this ability even
existed like when we do ad hoc groups
what we do is we look at if you're not
if if if you if who we look at who's not
here and who needs to be here so that we
have a balanced discussion on an issue
and that frequently I think doesn't
happen here and that's why I like that
kind of group to solve these
problems representative
McKay thank you Mr
chairman uh I have to
admit that I was going to ask a question
about
motivation and I do have some concerns
about why we're
only asking questions about
circumcision uh but I won't ask that
question thank you Mr chairman thank you
other
comments seeing none let's move on to
sb400 relative to patient access to
medical
thoughts seeing
none okay moving on uh to SB 458
relative to the dispensing of certain
one no
okay and finally and I know
representative McAn had a chair the
subcommittee on this final
one SB 95 relative to certification of
Alcohol and Other Drug use treatment
facilities I know we had at least one
subcommittee meeting I I sat in on it um
and unfortunately he can't be with us
this morning he will be here this
afternoon the executive session
representative
Shapiro yes um representative Weber and
myself participated in those
subcommittees and I think um can tell me
if I've got this wrong but I think there
was you know
a general
consensus that there was a usefulness
that would come out of um certification
of
um certain substance use disorder
programs that are currently not overseen
by um any um by DHHS in any way and um I
think those we kind of narrowed when we
first had the hearing it was very
confusing about what kind of
um facilities we were talking about what
kind of programs we were talking
about and um and in fact um the news
reports that had stirred us to bring
this bill happened in a residential
program and there already is oversight
over residential program so it was very
confusing um but I think in our
subcommittee work we decided that it
would be useful to have some level of
certification
of um I think they were broadly
called out outpatient um substance use
disorder programs which includes um day
treatment intensive day treatment
programs such as this and um
representative mlan was pursuing getting
more specific language written but I
don't we didn't you know we agreed to
vote on um suggesting that this bill um
be approved for further legislation
before we saw in the specific language
so um I think it was the consensus of
the group that it was a good idea to
um recommend further
legislation representative Weber and I
would agree with all of that and I think
that what this is an example of one
where we did actually make some progress
in the drafting it wasn't ready to go
and of course it has to be as we have
noted introduced in the next
legislature but
um the bill as it came to us had
significant drafting issues in it and we
had significant issues of understanding
exactly what the aims were and what it
was going to cover and in this case I
think we came to a considerable amount
more
clarity um
and uh the other part of the discussion
and I'm sorry that representative
Merchant couldn't be with us today but
he's um otherwise engaged was that um
there was the issue
of certification of Staff members versus
certification of a
facility and the concerns that we had
were if you only rely on the
certification of Staff
members um it's possible that the staff
members go down the line but the
facility hires somebody else and the
problem occurs again and again and again
because the the um facility has a
particular bent that is perhaps not as
appropriate and the concern I think for
all of us is that the people who are
being treated at these facilities are at
a particular vulnerable spot in their
lives and we want to be sure that the
care that they are getting is optimal so
representative Shapiro I think in the
end um in the initial um in the initial
hearings that we had in this committee
there was some discussion about um the
facility itself like the building and I
think we kind of narrow it in on we're
not talking about the licensed
clinicians because there's already
oversight over them and we're not
talking about the facility necessarily
but we're really talking about the
program um so um and and and we we did
not want to kind of have oversight
narrow the scope of the program because
we know there's a lot of different um
views on what makes a good substance use
disorder program there's all kinds of
models that have been used some of them
now
discredited um but certainly there's not
full agreement about what the right way
is to treat someone with a substance use
disorder so we wanted to we wanted when
this eventually happens to allow for
Innovation and allow for um
variation um but to have some oversight
on
[Music]
um
efficacy and and and efficacy and
ethical considerations within that
program thank you and can I just say one
more sure which is I want I want to give
representative mlan even though he's not
here um my appreciation for pursuing
this because it's kind of a dry subject
and I think he had mixed feelings I
think he
um I think he didn't feel so positive
about it then some but then some people
his constituencies thought it was a a
needed idea and he um really did a very
very good job of chairing the committee
and um gathering information
and um encouraging people to come to
talk about it so I give him a lot of
credit thank
thoughts okay I'm seeing none all right
that that concludes all of the bills
that we're going to be considering this
afternoon um any final thoughts oh yes
representative Murphy uh just a question
maybe your request um when we meet this
afternoon to exact these bills at 1 o'
is it possible to have um in in
representative Shapiro's comments made
me think of this was were any of the
bills acted upon during the summertime
was there a subcommittee was there a
recommendation if so what was it uh at
the beginning so that you know we can
table set the very beginning of every
discussion that they did or did not have
a subcommittee meeting and if so what
were the outcomes what were the
recommendations made at the time sure
there are only two functioning
subcommittees uh again that was on HP
554 FN and SB 495 unfortunately okay
that's what I thought because that's
what I heard you know but um I was part
of 554 I don't know if I was a true
member or I just kind of sat in and made
chair I don't know whatever uh I know
what the recommendations out of that
were and what the changes were so I
appreciate that that those are the only
two that people wanted to enjoy their
summer they didn't want to be doing this
stuff gotcha I understand that thank you
any other thoughts any other final
comments before we oh yes representative
McKay thank you Mr chairman uh this may
be the last time this committee meets
I'm
thinking uh and I I just wanted to
comment on the
individuals uh who decided not to come
back uh and I'm very appreciative of
those who decided to come back but it's
going to be a great loss to this uh
committee uh for some of the people who
become close friends uh over the session
uh so I just wanted to comment and I'm
kind of looking at the ones
that are extremely important to me um
and wanted to thank them for what they
have done
[Music]
and encourage them as one of them said I
may be over there that's not a threat
that that that's a a wonderful thing
that people can do and Joe is one of the
last social workers left uh so I'm
hoping that we can replace that person
but I felt it was very important having
served on this committee for a very long
time that this is one of the best
committees and I want to thank the chair
for his uh fairness and reliability as
well thank you very much thank you
representative
McKay um any anyone else any other final
comments okay why don't we U at this
point we'll I'm going to declare a
oh
e
he
good afternoon everyone and welcome back
to the house committee on Health and
Human Services and elderly
Affairs we uh had a work session this
morning and um one over all 13 of our
bills to be considered this afternoon
and at this time we're going to enter
executive session to um make
recommendations as to Future to
recommend or not recommend for future
legislation uh with that I'd like to
open it up and start with House Bill 554
FN uh do I have a
motion representative
Murphy thank you Mr chairman I recommend
um uh for future legislation for House
Bill 54 554 representative Murphy
recommends uh that excuse me moves that
554 be recommended for future
legislation is there a
second uh okay representative M beat you
to it representative Nal any discussion
on this motion representative Murphy do
you wish to speak to your motion uh we
spent um as one of the only two bills
that had uh work sessions this uh summer
we spent uh two fairly long sessions led
by the able uh representative Nagel and
um uh we made some recommendations and
one of the biggest recommendations was
that we go forward with future
legislation uh with some of the caveats
that we discussed earlier this morning
so I would recommend that we um
recommend for future legis ation um
going
forward any other discussion
representative McKay did you want to
speak to you a second or you all
set okay any other
discussion seeing none I'll ask that the
clerk call the
roll you're not going to trick me by
asking your name first po here so
representative Leon
yes uh substituting for representative
yes uh representative kofalt
yes representative
mlan
yes representative Seth King yes
representative Lisa Missour yes
representative Nal yes substituting for
and I won't say this every time but this
is the first only time that I will say
it substituting for um uh representative
palov is representative
papovich um Muller
yes representative we Weber yes
representative McKay
yes representative Nutter upam yes
representative Murphy yes representative
tles
yes
yes and representative m Donald
yes did I miss anybody representative
Shapiro
yes yes
yes sorry I skipped right over you I
think that is everybody in this
three the Y's have 14 the Nays
none 14 to zero 14 to
zero yep maybe that sh did you vot I
voted did
you representative Murphy voted
okay the ey on him
yes who was missing
here
yes your vote six 15 to
nothing I want to thank representative
Murphy for filling in for representative
King CL not doing a very job now it's
not an easy job I've done it but thank
you for doing this okay all committee
reports the deadline the absolute
deadline is October 25th obviously the
sooner the better so that U I'm sure
there'll be as always some last minute
report so the sooner they you can get
any of these in the better
representative
Nel um you're you're probably the best
suited unless representative Murphy
objects I don't object okay yeah if you
great okay next up is HB 580 FN
establishing a child children's vision
screening initiative within the State
Medicaid Program do I have a
motion representative Weber I would move
recommended for further
legislation representative Weber
recommend for future legislation is
second representative Shapiro
seconds representative Weber do you want
to speak to your motion I simply think
that
um an answer prevention is worth a pound
of cure that um setting up a program and
getting it instituted so kids get
checked early and interventions if
needed are started early is always a
good thing and tends to save a
significant amount of dollars in the
long run as well as um changing people's
lives
so thank you any other
discussion representative Lon uh thank
you Mr chairman I would like to uh note
that the reason this went to interim
study is because there still were many
many things that were uncertain given
the language of this bill um and my
question is whether or not this is
recommending sort of notionally of this
General idea for future legislation or
to build it as a model off of this um
this existing
bill I would definitely say that it was
the former it was the um concept rather
than having this bill be the
model um okay so I'm trying to figure
out where I am okay um thank
you other
discussion representative L on um yes I
the largest part within this um is some
of the those details do matter to me a
lot if we're looking at setting up more
clinics within our schools we're
bringing more and more opportunities
where we're sort of blending the
education Mission with the healthcare
Mission I know there's been a larger
move towards that and there's so many
different open-ended questions that
while I agree that in that we need to
make sure that children can see and that
there's a method to do so um the the
process of expecting everything to fall
within the Medicaid Program U or within
the school program um there's some
fundamental questions I have with how to
execute that and while I support all
children being able to see and getting
the Vision Care they need um even the
direction of doing this through Medicaid
and tying it to school attendance raises
significant concerns to me so while I
support all children being able to see
um even moving forward off of this
notional one presents problems to
me other
discussion seeing none I'll ask the
clerk to call the roll representative
Leon no
representative Lynn no Representative
kofalt
no Representative mlan
no representative Seth King
no representative Nagel
no representative papovich Muller no am
I pronouncing it
correctly yes no don't try to make me
vote Yes
okay is that a no it's a no on every
question I'm kidding representative
Weber yes representative McKay yes
representative uh another ofum yes
representative
Shapiro yes representative Murphy yes
Representative
tled no I'm
confused
yes and representative McDonald no you
where do they where is it list oh yes
represent merer no I thought I checked
you know but I did not I did this I
didn't say it
eight okay and now we will need the
is it a time no
nope
96 um
Nays nine
to9 all right it's m standing Kristen
that we now need to take the other vote
right okay I'll I'll move uh not
recommend for future legislation and
representative Leon moves not to
recommend is there a second
representative Missour
seconds any other
ready
yes representative Lynn yes
representative kofalt yes representative
mlan
yes representative Seth King
yes representative Missour
yes representative Nal
yes representative papovich Muller yes
on the motion yes on the
name representative Weber
no representative McKay no
representative nut upam
no representative Shapiro
no representative Murphy no
Representative tles
yes 9
to6 recommended not for future
recommendation I'll write that okay now
it's
the do we need two reports on that or
just one we're not allowed two reports
there just one so just be representative
okay okay next up is House Bill 608 FN
establishing pilot program to support
the Bureau of devel develop yeah
developmental Services we design
representative Lon um thank you Mr
chairman I move not recommended for
future
legislation second and representative we
seconds I we you wish to speak to your
motions speak brief sure um thank you
this bill was introduced during a time
of great uncertainty regarding the
redesign of the Bureau for developmental
Services it was retained by the
committee to continue the discussion
surrounding the implementation of the
redesign and we met both in the spring
and fall of 2023 stakeholders were able
to come together and while we
recommended this for interim study to
keep the Forum alive it was not needed
um the process worked and future
legislation is not
needed any other
discussion okay I'm saying
none ready when the clerk is ready call
please House Bill 608 recommendation is
not for future study representative leam
representative kofalt
yes representative Mark mlan yes
representative Seth King yes
representative Missour yes
representative Nagel yes representative
papovich meller
yes representative Weber yes
representative McKay
yes representative Nutter upam yes
representative Shapiro
yes representative Murphy yes
representative Tes yes representative
McDonald
yes 15 to Z the vote is 15 to zero in
favor of not recommended for future
legislation okay thank you MH and moving
the house bill 1010 relative to
expanding maternity options in mid rerey
motion representative L I'll move
recommended for future
second representative kofalt
representative kofalt seconds the motion
to recommend for future legislation do
you wish to speak to your motion uh yes
thank you uh this bill sought to remove
barriers to midwives attending home
births um by setting some guard rails on
what and what wasn't permitted within
the administrative rules surrounding um
the scope of practice for midwives um I
think further discussion needs to happen
in order to balance the risks and the
opportunities however we do need to
recognize that we're looking at the
potential of um having more and more
unattended home births if we're not able
to accommodate U mothers whose wishes
cannot be accommodated either with a
certified midwife or in the hospital
setting and where they may be going out
of state to neighboring states like
Massachusetts where some of these are
permitted by their equivalent of
certified midwives um while I recognize
that there were s there were various
concerns about the implementation and
how it was done um that's why we would
leave to a future legisl legislature how
better to um how better to accommodate
the risk preferences of different
parents other discussion representative
Shapiro yes thank you well well I think
there's um Merit in um providing as um
many options as possible for people to
um decide on their own risk tolerance um
and while I also think that there are
merits to the arguments
um from a lot of the more medically
oriented people on on this committee
that um these not might be very unsafe
for me the the determining Factor is
really that um in legislation we are
um we are saying that the the
the Midwifery Council which is the very
Council that is tasked with um providing
um the scope of practice then we are
turning around and telling them what
they can do and what they can't do and
so for that reason alone I would vote um
against recommending it for future um
for future
discussion another
discussion okay Mr clerk I'm sorry
representative King thank you Mr chair
um to address representative Shapiro's
concerns I think
that councils like the Midwifery Council
they know that they're in a tough
position because on the one hand they
want to promote Midwifery they believe
in the practice but they also know that
if anything bad happens that they're
going it's going to look bad for them
and it could result in negative
legislation against Midwifery so they
they're maybe in a position where they
feel they have to be more conservative
than they otherwise would be I think if
they if they have their DRS they
probably
support the provisions in this
legislation
but they can't do it themselves because
of the consequences that could come from
it whereas we the legislator Branch who
has the ultimate authority over these
councils um and ultimately the law um we
can we can let's just say be less
conservative so that's uh to address
your concern for me the reason why I'm
supporting this is because um I just
find it to be um in congruous as I as I
said in the work session that um people
have a legal authority to terminate
intentionally a pregnancy but to not
have access
to Midwifery um that doesn't make any
sense to me whatsoever um and then last
um you know I'm a California Refugee and
uh when I moved to the state of New
Hampshire I met a a lady who is also
from California and um she was a midwife
and she was a felon because she she was
in the room she wasn't the one
delivering the baby but she was in the
room and during the process she touched
the baby and that was enough to make her
a felon in the state of California so I
don't know what the penalties would be
in New Hampshire but we have a situation
where a person could be giving birth
outside of a hospital and somebody who's
just a random person not involved with
Midwifery would potentially have the
legal ability to deliver that baby but
somebody who's professionally a
midwife might not have the legal ability
to deliver that baby that also doesn't
make any sense so um to me I like the
idea of decriminalizing people from
doing something that our ancestors have
done for thousands of years without
legal repercussions so we need to end
the one mid rerey thank
you representative Nel um I just wanted
to point out that I believe there's
substantially better better ways to
address the obstetrical crisis in this
state than
discussion none I'll ask the CLK to call
the
rooll motion before us is recommendation
for future legislation on House Bill
1010 representative Leong
yes representative Lynn
yes representative kofalt yes
representative mlan yes
representative Seth King yes
representative Missour yes
representative
Nagel representative papovich meller yes
representative Weber no representative
McKay
no representative Nutter upam no
representative Shapiro no representative
Murphy
no representative Tes no and
yes 8
to7
for favor of uh future
legislation okay thank
you okay next up is House Bill 1067
relative to a patient's right to
sterilization treatment do I have a
motion representative Leon I'm sure I
move recommended for future
legislation is there a
second representative papovich Muller
seconds representative L do you wish to
speak to your motion yes thank you Mr
chairman this bill sought to remove
barriers to ster sterilization treatment
for Consulting consenting adults and to
provide protection for those who provide
this treatment of note are women with
debilitating endometriosis or other
conditions who are denied the standard
treat of hysterctomy because of
physician concern about their future
reproductive wishes additionally through
this bill and others it's become
apparent that P the patients Bill of
Rights in RSA 151 only applies to care
in certain Healthcare facilities in the
state and not into patient rights in
general so future legislation P should
put place place patient protections
including the access to sterilization
treatment in a different section of
law other discussion representative
Weber
thank you Mr chairman
um my concern with this
legislation is the way it was
drafted um but my other concern is the
stories that we heard of people
who uh went through very very difficult
lack of the care that they believed they
needed and that was proved later on to
be helpful to
them
um I have my my concern with the bill
was all the particulars
about how we were going to effectuate
this if there was something very limited
which stated that uh the procedure could
not be denied solely on the
basis that a medical professional about
opinion about what you might want later
on in your life was better for you than
what you thought was good for you um I I
would be much more favorably um inclined
towards such
legislation so um for that
reason I come down on the side of voting
uh recommend
but um I do have real reservations about
the mechanisms contained in this
Bill thank you other discussion
representative papichi Mller thank you
I'm encouraged to hear the comments of
my colleagues
um in the previous few votes we've made
it clear that we don't necessarily
support the legislation as written but
we support the intent with the
understanding that future legislation
may be written in such a way to address
address concerns expressed by this
committee so I would like to encourage
you know everyone to uh consider
supporting this important bill at the
end of the day it comes down to our
agency and our ability to control what
happens to our body and I think that if
we believe in Freedom and the freedom to
control what you know is happening to us
this is a prime example of a bill that
you know deserves support and again I'm
sure that every word in Bill matters and
it can be maybe made clearer that you
know the pre-procedure cannot be denied
solely on the basis of that I thought
the language was already doing that but
I'm just one of 400 so um I would
appreciate everybody's um support for
this again knowing that future
legislation will have to go through a
full legislative process thank you other
discussion saying on I'll ask the clle
call all
motion is the motion is recommendation
for future legislation on House Bill
1067 representative Leon yes
representative Lynn yes representative
kofalt
yes representative mlan yes
representative Seth King yes
representative Missour yes
representative Nagel
no representative papovich Muller yes
representative Weber
yes representative McKay
yes representative Nutter upam
yes
representative
Shapiro
yes representative Murphy no
Representative
tles
12-3 motion passes 12 to3
12-3 thank you next up is House Bill
1347 relative to administration of the
New Hampshire Refugee resettlement
program do I have a
motion representative
chapero I move that we not recommend for
future legislation
representative Shapiro recomend uh moves
we do not recommend is there a second
second representative Weber seconds
would you like to speak to your motion
representative
Shapiro um for one I we had a long
discussion about this this morning but
the prime sponsor um acknowledged when
he came to present the bill that this
didn't not really
meet his intentions in putting this bill
forward um
um and um
secondarily um
the program within the Department of
Human Services that um coordinates with
private nonprofits resettlement um
organizations um only works with a
select very select group of immigrants
which are
refugees and um the money is provided
for um their um Staffing and for the
limited amount of money that they're
able to um give out in terms of Grants
it's all federal money and the bill
itself talked only about State funds so
it
um I just think that the I just think
that it's irrelevant and also that
um it didn't really um meet the the
sponsor's intention and terms of having
a broader discussion about the effects
of immigration on our country so I think
that um any other bill that's put
forward would be so different from this
bill that it would not really be
related thank you representative TZ I
just want to reiterate having directed
The Office in which this program resides
um the as written it is completely
untenable these federal funds are
completely directed to one unique
purpose and the refugee program all
costs are completely federally funded
and there would be no way for it to be
changed to uh other people or um again
as uh represent sh pointed out there are
no State funds involved so untenable
discussion seeing none I'll ask cler to
call the role motion is to
not motion is not recommended for Former
Future legislation on House Bill 13
47 representative Leon
yes representative Lynn yes
representative kofalt yes representative
mlan
yes representative Seth King
no representative Missour yes
representative Nagel
yes representative papovich Muller yes
representative Weber yes
representative McKay yes representative
Nutter upam yes representative Shapiro
yes representative Murphy yes
representative tles yes representative
McDonald
yes V is 14 to1 in favor of the
recommendation that motion passes 14 to1
next up is House Bill 1661 FN relative
to immunization reporting requirements
motion representative cofal um I move to
recommend for future
legislation and representative mour
seconds the motion representative kofalt
do you wish to speak to your
motion yes I I the intent of the bill
is I believe to see that data is
available um given the very serious
concerns that have been raised about the
safety of certain vaccines in particular
the uh the covid
vaccine that that data be made available
such that uh it could be analyzed and
better understood uh that we could
better understand the the uh
correlations between um certain
vaccinations and certain causes of death
having said that the bill as
introduced um was I think uh
extraordinarily detailed and and
burdensome um it did not take a
lightweight approach to providing this
information
um so I I sort of understand the the
sentiment behind um going interim study
as as opposed to moving the bill forward
having said that I think um that if we
indeed want to follow the science we
ought to um we ought to have uh this
kind of data
available representative
Weber thank you for that and I
appreciate the caveat that it ought to
be done in a very different way this one
of the conversations we had this morning
was
about
um whether we recommend or not recommend
when where where the line comes between
recommendation and not recommendation
when we don't agree with the approaching
the bill uh this one for me crosses the
line into not recommending so I'm going
to oppose the
recommendation uh the reasons are this
uh the data that you're collect first of
all it's it's collecting the data in the
wrong Forum um because the amount uh the
number of people who certify deaths who
would have to be
incorporated into having access to the
vaccine registry is
um burdensome and it's burdensome of a
procedure that happens at a time when um
collecting vaccine records is
particularly inappropriate um in in my
case my late husband died at home and
the hospice nurse uh certified the death
uh she would not have had any access to
the vaccine data that's requested
here if you collect the data however
it's collected as this requires you have
not two columns but three columns you
have people whose data is in the
registry and can be retrieved however
burdensome that is then you have people
for whose death certificate has no data
but what you don't know is how many of
those people for whom there is no data
are people who were vaccinated but chose
not to become part of the registry as is
their right or how many of them are
people who are not
vaccinated as is also their right so I
don't believe that when we look at this
data we're comparing Apples to Apples we
don't have any way of separating out in
the no data colum whether that means
that they weren't vaccinated or they
simply didn't want to be reported and
then there were the issues for
Department of Health and Human Services
in terms of the amount of extra work
that was going to be for them the other
um thing that was mentioned this morning
that I will just note was that um at a
time when we are having medical
professionals assume more and more and
more clerical stuff and data collection
stuff and Hoops to jump through this was
one more hoop that perhaps came at a
particular inappropriate time so and
done in an inappropriate way so I'm
coming down on the side of saying no to
discussion representative Nel I've been
going back and forth on the thank you Mr
chairman I've been going back and forth
on this bill for a lot of reasons I the
question that I was focusing a lot on
this morning is what is our role here
and and and you kind of addressed that
again but this is one bill that I really
think that should have had a study group
and it should have really looked at this
in detail and should have gotten um
testimony from the people that were
going to be involved in collecting this
data to find out how burdensome it was
and it wasn't and that was not done and
it was actually when I looked at my
notes that was something that I had
recommended when we actually heard this
bill originally because that
information's not there I have to say
that to me it crosses the line too I
think the concept's good um I just think
the way we collect the data and how we
affect the the practice of healthc Care
at a critical time has to be considered
and and certainly what we're doing here
is not changing that F future
legislation can't come but what it is
saying is it can't come in this format
and that's why I'm going to vote
discussion representative t yes hi yes
thank you um I I would to me uh given my
training the desire for wanting to know
if there's an association between
certain diagnoses at time of death or
causes of death and any historical
vaccines that may have been administered
is completely a um you know a historical
uh or retrospective you look at data
sets it's a it's a it's something you
just do with a computer if you have
access to the data and you don't need to
have the person who's certifying the
death know anything about it so How It
Was Written is what makes it untenable
the idea that the person certifying the
death would be the one who would review
the the records for immunization is
completely unnecessary and it's what
makes it impossible um and the cost
would be much more than what was written
in the fiscal note um given the burden
that it would it would impose so again
untenable thank you other discussion
seeing none um I'll call for the vote
ask cl to call a roll motion is to
recommend uh for future legislation on
House Bill 1661 FM representative Leon
yes representative Lynn yes
representative kofalt yes representative
mlan yes representative Seth King
no representative Missour
yes represent representative Nagel
no representative papovich Mueller yes
representative Weber no representative
McKay
no representative nut upam
no representative Shapiro
no representative Murphy no
Representative
tles
motion fails at 7
to8 he motion fails to from uh 7 to8 do
I have another motion representative
Weber I'll move not recommended for
future legislation for all the reasons
that we've also already stated and also
I'm going to um raise the issue of the
fact that Based
on data from Massachusetts we were given
actual names associated with some of the
data when when we heard this the first
time around and I think the privacy
issues in this format are are simply A
Bridge Too Far um although if I'm
drafting a response is it fair for me to
put in that response uh that everybody
on the committee is concerned about
about
um assembling appropriate data about
vaccination and and consequences of
vaccination it's just that for those of
us in the majority we don't believe it's
this format any objections to
that
okay representative Murphy seconds the
motion um any other
discussion saying none and the clerk is
ready
motion is to not to recommend 1661 for
future
legislation this involves another piece
of
paper thank you T
okay um representative Leon yes
yes motion is not for recommendation
future list oh yeah sorry thank you no
oh I was confused no it's been a long
day I'll I'll stay with what you said
initially I appreciate that now I'm GNA
change mine to
know
I I would also like to change mine to
caffeine I should take the clerk's
prerogative but I will not I will
register your vote as intended
Representative kofalt no
Representative mlan
no representative Seth King
yes representative
Nal Representative papovich meller
no representative Weber yes
yes representative Nutter upam yes
representative Shapiro
yes representative Murphy yes
yes
chair the chair the chair no represented
and motion to not recommend for future
legislation passes 8 to7 okay motion
passes 8 to7 out to
recommend next up is hb1 1663 FN
relative to the confidentiality of
medical records and patient information
representative Lam uh thank you I move
recommended for future legislation is
there a
second representative maor seconds do
you wish to speak to your motion uh yes
thank you this bill sought to provide
protections and Clarity regarding
medical record confidentiality through a
repeal and replace method substantial
testimony opposing facets of current law
is overly restrictive suggested that
there's significant need to assess New
Hampshire's protections of patient
privacy in a more rigorous manner
particularly given the expanded public
awareness surrounding Hippa uh the
health insurance portability and
accountability Act was assumed to be a
privacy Protection Law when in reality
it facilitates easier sharing of patient
records federal law permits to be more
protective of patient privacy and um it
is recommended that future legislation
take into account uh views from multiple
stakeholders before legislation is
discussion I'm seeing
none when the clerk is ready I'll ask
him to call the role a motion is for
future recommended for future
representative Leon
yes representative Lynn yes
representative kofalt yes representative
mlan absolutely yes representative King
no representative Missour yes
representative Nagel yes
representative Papa VI Muller
yes representative
Weber
uh
upam representative
Shapiro
yes representative Murphy no
representative
tles
yes recommendation for future record
legislation passes 11 to4 motion passes
11 to4 to recommend House Bill 1663 for
future legislation
next up is House Bill 1693 FN relative
to the use of psychedelics for
therapeutic
purposes representative Leon uh thank
you Mr chairman I recommend uh
recommended for future
legislation is that for or not for yes
for future R legislation Y is there a
second representative
Kofa representative Landy wish to speak
to your motion yes thank you Mr chairman
New Hampshire state law currently
prevents research Andor treatments which
use schedule one psychedelic drugs
despite the expanding Research into this
area the Veterans Administration and
Massachusetts General Hospital are
currently conducting research for a
number of disorders using these drugs
and the FDA is granted breakthrough
therapy designation for some
psychedelics we recommend future
legislation to permit patients access to
clinical trials and other therapy
without the need to cross state lines
for
care representative Weber
I'm sorry representative kofalt she for
me okay sorry and and I just wanted to
um say thank you to representative Leon
we we discussed this significantly
earlier in the work session and uh she's
very succinctly
expressed uh the concerns that we had
not to stand in the way of appropriate
medical treatment and to encourage
medical treatment but the con concerns
we had with the bill is presented was it
was far too broad created a whole new
bureaucracy and it was
unclear how the supervision was going to
happen and that it was going to happen
in an appropriate setting so we want to
get out of the way of progress but we
don't want to set up a whole new
bureaucracy and I think that the
statement does
that
representative yeah I I think that
representative Weber touched on what I
wanted to to uh say which was that the
original bill was modeled after cannabis
legislation and this is a completely
different um category of treatment um
that what we are talking about is a
situation in which the use of these
substances is highly highly supervised
and um I think is showing great
Effectiveness in the treatment of PTSD
and other um other maladies and so um I
just want people to be very very clear
that this is um to to reiterate a point
we brought up earlier that this is is
entirely different from the the kind of
legislation that has uh made medical
cannabis um
legal representative n thank you Mr
chairman I'm going to just demonstrate
my hypocrisy and say that I really
cannot stand the format of the way this
bill was intended like the other Bill
however I really greatly appreciate the
way you wrote this up and I will support
that
other
discussion seeing none when the clerk is
ready motion is for future legis
recommend for future legislation on HB
1693 FN representative Leon yes
representative Lynn yes representative
kofalt yes representative Mark mlan yes
representative Seth King
yes representative Missour
yes representative Nal yes
representative papovich meller
yes representative Weber yes
representative McKay
no representative Nutter upam
yes representative Shapiro
yes representative Murphy yes
representative tles yes representative
motion passes 14 to1 motion passes 14
to1 on hb1 1693
FN good job next up is HP 1706 FN
relative to notice required prior to
motion do I have a
motion I'll make a motion repres Nel um
not not for further legislation you move
not to recommend for future legislation
representative Murphy
seconds representative Nagel do you wish
to speak to your motion um I think we
talked a lot about it this morning I
don't have a whole lot more to say I
just I I do like the concept that this
bill raised about looking at the whole
concept of informed consent which I
think really needs to be done however
the concept of requiring or putting in
stat statute and informed consent for a
single procedure on the basis of a
relatively small percentage of Americans
who who feel that way and we never did
hear from the others as we noted this
morning bothers me a lot and therefore I
I really can't support this it really
interferes with medical practice and I
discussion representative Leon uh thank
you Mr chairman representative Nagel if
you're going to write up the report are
you going to emphasize the informed
consent for everything and not for the
specific on this yeah okay and then I
can support that so thank you to me
that's a really important issue that I
really was glad that this bill raised
that and the other bill that
representative kushman brought up those
are critical bills to me so yes I will
emphasize that thank you does that mean
I'm writing it up yes yeah
please any other
discussion seeing none motion is to not
recommend for future legislation on
House Bill 1706
FM representative Leon yes
representative Lynn yes Representative
kofalt
no representative mlan
yes representative Seth King
no representative Missour
yes papich Miller I was going to say
representative Povich Muller if I'm
butchering that let me know if got four
or five more to go you are doing great
thank you perfect thank you is that a
yes yes thank
you representative Weber I'm two of the
yes representative McKay yes
representative nut upen
yes representative Shapiro
yes representative Murphy
yes representative fiz
yes and the chairman representative
McDonald
yes it passes 13-2 recommendation not to
have future legislation motion to not
recommend passes 13-2 on HP
1706 SB 400 relative to patient access
to medical records do I have a motion
representative
mlan thank you Mr chair I recommend for
future
legislation okay is there a second
second representative Le on seconds
representative McLean do you wish to
speak to your motion yeah uh thank you
Mr chair um I think as I recall back to
uh the testimony and the discussion at
the time the bill was heard everybody
agreed that you know the patients own
their records um and I don't think it's
fair that if you know someone engages an
agent because they're incapacitated that
they should be charged $4,000 as opposed
to
$6.50 however being practical um if you
went $6.50 across the board the third
party agencies that do the work would
basically go out of business so we we
did try to Amendment an amendment to try
to thread the needle I don't think the
amendment was able to settle in on the
the final solution but I think the
concept is good and if we can find a way
you know to do that I I don't think we
want to be punishing people that want
access to their information but would
want to engage another party to to
assist them in doing that so um I would
recommend for future legislation thank
discussion saying no other
discussion okay the motion is uh to
recommend for future legislation on SB
400 and the clerk is ready
representative Leon yes representative
Lynn
yes representative kofalt yes
representative mlan yes representative
Seth King
no representative Missour yes
representative papovich meller
yes representative Weber yes
yes representative nut upam
yes representative Murphy
yes 12 to3 passes motion passes 12 to3
to recommend s sp400 for future
legislation next up is SV
458 relative to the dispensing of
certain medications do I have a
[Music]
motion yes
representative Nel know this is like the
yours not not to recommend or okay okay
there a second representative lay on
seconds you wish to speak to your
motion little bit I'm the expert on this
thinking our our group is um not here
today um I was drawn by his um uh
committee report court on this bill
originally um where he felt that unless
certain things happened that he did not
recommend further legislation as M I
don't know if they have or they have not
but um based on that alone I think that
I would rely on his judgment and say
no representative Lon uh thank you Mr
chairman and thank you representative
Nagel um with that reviewing the
previous information I would say that
the current status is that it's not
recommended for future legislation but
if we find that there's additional Road
Blocks with the Board of Pharmacy then
the situation would have changed so as
long as the Board of Pharmacy is moving
ahead in order to find a way to
accommodate these needs there's no need
for
discussion I'm seeing no other
discussion the motion is against
recommending for future legislation on
SB
458 and when the clerk is ready I'll ask
him to call the rooll uh representative
Leon
yes representative Lynn yes
representative kofalt yes representative
mlan yes representative Seth King
yes representative Missour yes
representative Nel yes representative
papichi meller
yes representative Weber yes
representative McKay
yes representative Nutter upam yes
representative Shapiro
yes representative Murphy is a yes and
representative tles
yes I'll count
anyway representative McDonald McDonald
representative McDonald yes yes I'll
count
anyway when I was a clerk I always
forgot the chairman 15 to nothing motion
passes 15 to zero on Senate Bill 458
against recommending for future
legislation and the final bill of the
day sp495 representative mlan I suspect
you may want to make this motion uh yes
Mr chair I I would move recommend for uh
future
legislation second representative R
seconds would you like to speak to your
motion representative McLean yes thank
you Mr chair um let me just look at my
not we did have a subcommittee and uh we
did meet um had a conversation with the
new mayor Manchester and some of the
most important legislation that we can
address up here in in conquer is that
you know relating to substance abuse
treatment Manchester is Ground Zero in
in many respects and so um even though
I'm a limited government person um and
really believe in in the market in a lot
of areas you know when people are coming
out and they're looking for treatment to
deal with substance abuse it's not like
going out and looking for someone you
know on Angie's List to to to fix the
roof on your house and in in
conversation with the mayor who himself
is a recovered addict you know he said
if someone comes out of Valley Street
jail clean we have a rare chance to keep
them that way and if we send them to a
place um that's you know the wild west
and and the counselor is not fully
through their own recovery Journey then
that opportunity is really lost um and
so the
subcommittee Met and we went through a
lot of the concerns that were brought
forth by the full committee and we don't
have uh the final language but we did go
through and and develop a lot of what we
think that final language should look
like and we're not really voting on that
as much as the concept um but the
language that we did agree on uh gets
rid of the residential stuff this is
focusing on the outpatient and it really
is limiting the scope and getting rid of
some of the concerns that people like
representative Merchant had is just
going to infringe on AA and things like
that so um a lot of members of the Phil
full committee were saying why not just
let oplc do this since the individual
practitioners they're already licensed
by oplc and and the response back over
and over again in in the subcommittee
hearings is that really we want to be
understanding what is best practice in
the facilities themselves and that kind
of led to the next question
is that going to choke off and maybe uh
strangle Innovation but actually when we
spoke to people such as Granite recovery
that take Medicaid and they're already
regulated they're saying this is a very
Innovative field that is moving away
from cookie cutter approaches to to more
targeted approaches and that nothing
within the Medicaid rule framework has
stopped them from making you know those
Innovations and so they don't anticipate
that any rules that we would be bringing
forth with with DHHS would do the same
the the the consensus seemed to be from
the people who were testifying is that a
larger barrier to Innovation might be
from the insurance companies which are a
little bit more conservative and are
thinking you know maybe we want to just
be ensuring stuff that's already out
there and is already well established
but from a perspective of with these
rules themselves impede Innovation I I
think the consensus with that not the
case the other thing we kind of asked
was you know why not just rely heavily
on the utsman if we have abuses or
things like that um part of the bill
brought forth the utsman provision and
we we talked about some different
examples such as uh the right to know
edsman but the reason that the right to
know edsman works is because there's
already a set of rules that's there
which is um RSA 91a and so if you were
to go to the RSA to
the the the right to know Ombudsman and
say we're looking for a ruling on that
if you don't have the rules then what do
they refer to so again the rules kind of
have to come first so I think that you
know on balance we don't have the final
language but I think this is something
that that's really important to people
going into recovery I think it's
something that's really important to
those of us who are in Manchester who
are at the center of this thing and so
what I would love to do is have the
committee come forth with a
recommendation for future legislation so
that we can bring it back next year uh
thank you Mr chair thank you
representative uh King and then
representative
Pall thank you Mr chair I just want to
thank uh representative mlan for the
work you did on this and um and being in
touch with uh mayor of Manchester um I
initially was going to oppose uh
recommending the bill but based on
everything you just said now including
the fact that you shared my concerns
with the original language of the bill
I'm I'm going to follow your lead and
support this um thank you thank you
representative
kofalt I'm I'm going to vote against
this I I am Gravely concerned that um
this stands in the way of innovation I
understand that you've you've made some
arguments that it it does not um I think
it stands in the way of innovation I
have serious concerns about the impact
on
um AA and similar programs that you know
despite reassurances that this is not
aimed at them um I think once we start
down this path that is where it goes so
I will be voting
against other discussion representative
Lon um thank you Mr chairman I think
that there's been some interesting
viewpoints that have come up I
appreciate the work that you've done um
I I haven't been able to read the work
that you put together and um just trying
to look at this trying to look at our
impact Within These it looks to me by
counting votes that there'll be the
votes to pass it as recommended for
future legislation but then also
recognizing the other concerns I feel
compelled personally to vote against the
recommendation for future legislation
not because I don't want to see what you
bring forward and I do hope to see it
filed but so that there's not an
overwhelming number of us all supporting
it giving it toward the Mandate because
I am concerned about impacting the whole
ecosystem of recovery because um drug
abuse and Recovery takes many paths and
I don't I don't want to stop anybody
from getting the treatment they need
while I also want to make sure that
vulnerable people aren't taken advantage
of so you know got to pick one way or
the other and I'm just going to try not
to stack that but I'm releasing anybody
who's following my vote from uh
following my vote on this
one representative
wber thank you and I I just really want
to Second everything that um
representative mlan said um the I we
learned a lot in the subcommittee and I
was persuaded you know I'm very much of
the opinion that uh this is not an area
where one size is going to fit all and
that we need to have a range of
treatments because some are going to be
more effective for one person than for
another person uh but I was persuaded in
the course of our discussion that we
were not putting roadblocks in the way
uh but that we need to protect people
who are in a vulnerable part of their
life so uh I come out in favor and I
just wanted to also pass along that um
uh I'm I'm sure your ears were burning
this morning because there were a lot of
very complimentary remarks about your
chairmanship of the committee and your
approach to the process and your
willingness to take it on so we're all
grateful for that however we come
I seeing none ask the clerk to call a
roll motion is to recommend for future
legislation on Senate Bill
no representative mlan
yes representative Seth King
yes representative Missour
no representative Weber
yes representative McKay
yes representative nut upam
yes representative Shapiro
yes representative Murphy is a yes
representative ches
yes 11 to4 passes motion passes 11 to4
to recommend Senate Bill 495 for future
legislation
that concludes the bills that were
noticed for today that concludes the
bills period representative
Weber Mr chairman before we before we
leave I just wanted to extend my thanks
to all the members of the committee for
all of the struggles we have faced
together over the last two years and I
wanted to particularly thank you for the
way you have run this committee I I
believe that you have been very fair to
everybody and that um when when one is
in a minority it helps a lot to feel
that you have been allowed to express
your views thoroughly and then if people
vote against you it's not a fun thing
but you at least you feel like your your
views have been heard so I very much
appreciate your running of the committee
and I wanted to extend my thanks thank
you representative Weber and I've also
enjoyed working with everyone on the
committee uh and it's thanks to you
thanks to the vice chairman
representative Lon uh our Clerk I forgot
to thank him the last time we met um and
he wasn't able to join us today but Bill
King representative Bill King from
Milford who was not running for a
election I I really appreciate his
efforts and and very much appreciate
representative Murphy and the numerous
times he has filled in uh for those of
you who are not running again uh and I
don't know if there's anyone well
representative shabo I know you're not I
don't know if there's anyone else here
not
running um oh I'm sorry I'm sorry
um I guess I don't want to accept that
but but anyway um uh you know good luck
on your new adventures you and we'll see
what the voters have to say for all of
us but again thank you all very very
much and um before we close any final